Solve for p.
We have the absolute value of p minus 12
plus 4 is less than 14.
So, let's just do this one step at a time.
The first thing we wanna do is we really
just wanna isolate the part that has the
absolute value.
So, to do that we can just get rid of this
positive 4 here.
We can do that by subtracting 4 from both
sides of the inequality.
And so the left hand side the positive 4
and the negative 4
cancel out we're just left with the
absolute value of p minus 12.
And on the right hand side it, we get 14
minus
4 is 10 and we still have the less than
sign.
So we have the absolute value of p minus
12 is less than 10.
So let's just think about it a little bit.
If I were to tell you, if I were to tell
you that
the absolute value of x is less than 10
what does that mean?
That means that the distance from x to 0
has to be less than 10.
So if I were to draw a number line, if I
were to draw a number
line and put 0 here we can only go up 10
away and even that's too far.
It has to be less than 10.
So if this is positive 10 it would have to
be less than positive 10 cuz 10 is exactly
10 away.
We have to be less than 10 away from 0.
And then we could go all the way to the
left until negative 10
and even that we wouldn't be able to
include because its absolute value is 10.
It's not less than 10 but negative 9
negative 9.999 we could include all of
those things.
The absolute value of any of those things
is gonna be less than 10.
So another way to write this, this
absolute value inequality
is that x could be, x could be greater
than negative 10, x
could be greater than negative 10 and x
needs to be
less than 10 or we can write this as x is
between.
So negative 10 is kinda the bottom
boundary and we're not going to include
it.
X is going to be greater than that and is
less than 10.
So this is another way to write the
absolute value of x is less than 10.
Is essentially saying that x has to be
between negative 10
and 10 and it can't be either negative 10
or 10.
We're not, there's no equals sign here.
So, the same exact logic.
Instead of an x we have a p minus 12 here.
So, we can write the absolute value of p
minus 12 is less than 10 is
saying that negative 10 is less than p
minus 12 which is less than 10.
And we can just solve this compound
inequality all
at once by isolating the p in the middle.
The best way to isolate the p in the
middle we wanna get rid of this negative
12.
So let's add 12 to all three, all three
sections of this compound inequality.
And so we get negative 10 plus 12 is
positive 2.
And then is less than p minus 12 plus 12
is just p.
And then is less than 10 plus 12 is 22.
So p is greater than 2 and less than 22.
So if we were to plot it on a number line
our solution set looks like this.
So this might be 2 over here.
This might be 22 over here maybe 0 sitting
right over here.
P is greater than 2.
It's not greater than or equal to so we
have to not fill this in.
It has to be an open circle it's only
greater than and it's less than 22.
It's not less than or equal to so we're
not gonna fill that circle in.
And it's everything, it's everything in
between.
And we can verify it for ourselves.
Let's try a value that might work out
well.
Well, 12 is in between these two numbers.
It's in our magenta region right here.
So let's try p is equal to 12.
So if you have 12 minus 12.
So it's the absolute value of 12 minus 12
plus 4 which should be less than 14.
So this is 0 plus 4 which needs to be less
than 14 and 4 is definitely less than 14.
So 12 worked 0 shouldn't work.
Lets try 0.
Zero minus 12 so it's the absolute value
of 0.
I wanna do this in a different color.
It is the absolute value of 0 minus 12
plus 4.
This should not be less than 14.
This should not work.
So we get the absolute value of negative
12.
Plus 4 should not be less than 14.
Then we should end up with a contradiction
here.
So we have 12 plus 4 less than 14 we end
up with 16 is less than 14 which is not
true.
So 0 does not work so at least we're
feeling pretty good.
We took something outside of our solution
set didn't
work something inside of our solution set
it did work.